today is live broadcast effective
workplace training for English language
learners I am Judy alorica blab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window or try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
sharing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Paula Clifford
Paula Clifford is co-owner of animal
care training services a cts where she
provides training services for the
biomedical community and executive
director of the Pennsylvania Society for
biomedical research he s the arm where
she is responsible for the vision and
oversight of the statewide organization
I will now turn it over the Paula for
her presentation thank you
thank you so much Judy thank you so much
duty well good afternoon everyone or
morning depending where you're coming
from thank you so much for joining me
today and I look forward to hearing your
feedback and your ideas as we go through
the presentation alright so first I just
wanted to let you know that this is one
of my very favorite topics and training
as a trainer it's so important for us to
create a safe of that effective learning
environment for everybody it's hard to
create a good environment if you don't
understand or know your audience when
you're you're getting trained to be an
effective trainer one of the things that
you learn in the very beginning is to
get to know your audience so when we're
talking about our audience members who
have english as not not their first or
second or third or fourth language it's
really important that we try to get to
know them so many years ago i attended a
session at lotte the laboratory animal
welfare a training exchange and that's
when I really sort of got the bug for
for this kind of a thing I saw I'm not
sure if any of you in the audience saw
this presentation but it was given by
genevieve Friedland and she actually
worked at ALS at the time she doesn't
work there now and it was actually a
court it was a session on teaching
English language learners the points in
that session impacted every single
training that I've conducted after it it
really helped me understand audience and
audience members from a variety of
different cultural backgrounds so from
that point on I adjusted my training for
all different types of learners making
my training more effective the the
presentation actually was developed into
a course so you if you have access to
the AOS learning library i highly
suggest you check it out it's still on
there and then last October I had the
opportunity to moderate a panel of
experts at a loss on teaching
at the English language learner so the
information that I learned there as the
moderator on as well as tips that I I
learned will will be shared during this
presentation as well can I just um so I
just wanted to start out with a quick
quick check on the audience so I could
get to know you a little bit so if you
could use your QA sort of chat box there
and just let me know how many of you out
there are responsible for teach for for
training
so I'm just going to wait a minute and
see if some of you could just sort of
chat in and say yes I'm responsible for
training or okay great alright so I see
we do have some trainers out there great
I love to hear your experiences and your
tips as well later in the presentation
okay so just so you know how we're going
to sort of go through this presentation
on if you read the abstract and looked
at the objectives you know that we're
really just going to focus on areas
where strategies to support english
language learners can be implemented and
um and then i'll share some strategies
and i'm just going to really share a
couple focus things because i really
want you to walk away with some things
that you can actually go back to the
workplace and implement so i'll do this
volley just get us getting us all on the
same purpose on the same page on the
purpose of effective workplace training
for English language learners identify
areas where easy areas where strategies
could support these learners and then
I'll share some strategies and tips on
how you can implement these things to
increase your training effectiveness and
I'll also end with sharing some
additional resources there's there's a
ton of support out there so I wanted to
share some of those resources for you
okay so purpose right so diversity
having a group of people from different
cultural backgrounds gives you an
enormous benefit in providing very
different perspectives on a single issue
i think that's huge and if you've done
any reading or research in you know did
the diverse workplace or world you know
you you know this it really provides the
opportunity for a lot of different kind
of approaches resulting in a higher
incidence of finding effective solutions
it opens the door to a lot of creativity
and new ideas and it's so important for
our community as this community
especially because it allows us to
better address animal welfare and
ethical concepts within the right
context it's important to understand
that different cultures have different
you know perspectives on how animals
should be handled how animals should be
used about their status in the society
and that's really important because if
we don't understand that it's really
difficult it's such a complex subject as
it is if you're not understanding where
everybody's coming from it's really hard
to then be able to develop an effective
training and if you can understand that
your training can be effective which
will increase compliance okay um and
another you know a couple other things
is just practical reasons as well having
you know addressing in supporting
training for the English language
learner is really going to help minimize
discomfort tough interactions lack of
trust you know all these things that I
have up on the slide there and we could
probably go on and on and on and on on
you know an uncomfortable workplace is
an unproductive workplace effectively
managing a diverse workplace will
increase workplace satisfaction staff
morale and ultimately productivity right
and finally all these things do result
in better science and that's what we're
all here for better science and good
animal welfare so a supportive
collaborative environment with diverse
ideas really sets the stage for good
science and the highest standards of
animal care
okay but it's it's actually come with um
and us actually requires new skill set
so there's been several articles out
there and i'll talk about them a little
bit later this these there was an
article by dr. Stacy print and others
recently I think it was into March of
2004 and talks about cultural competence
and it really requires a new set of
skills you know skills that we typically
haven't been trained on you know
managers don't come in with it usually
supervisors staff people so on these
skills and I put some of them up there
on the slide you know you really need
someone that has interests drive and
energy to adapt cross-culturally you
need to possess an understanding of
culture and the role of culture and
personal interactions animal attachment
and service in transactions that might
seem obvious to some it's not obvious to
everybody and it's very important you
need to be aware and plan approaches and
monitor the effectiveness of cross
cultural interactions so just don't
assume that it's happening appropriately
really be aware of it evaluate it see
what's happening provide support for
your staff so these skill sets and
there's there's more shared in that
article are things that we have to think
about when where we're going to on this
talk focus focus on our English language
learner but it's good to point out that
when we're training our and I will share
some strategies on training your staff
here but something to think about in
those performance evaluations and
professional development of your staff
okay so on some areas where you could
easily implement I'm sure you all could
think of a ton of areas that you could
implement these things but if
here's a couple easy ones orientation so
when researchers or new staff start you
know very very much in the very
beginning of their time and whether
that's sort of the regulatory
orientation or facility orientation any
kind of an orientation is a great area
to try to implement some of these
strategies so I'll share some examples
later as we talk about the different
ones hands-on labs another great place
to implement some of these strategies
and an easy place you know just a couple
minor you know adjustments if you're not
already doing these things really can
help the effectiveness of your training
and then protocol waiting so this is
this is in regards to new researchers
that fall into this category you know
find out things that they're doing that
are very important to their job and
let's help them do it better so really
helping them with different vocabulary
you know vocabulary that's coming up a
lot things like that our great areas to
focus on and help make sure that there's
a good understanding so before I think
we're going to go into the strategies on
these these I'm going to go through
these one by one but these are these are
the strategy areas that I'm going to
focus on you know doing research
training visual using visual aids and
then some tips so I'm curious I have a
pull out there on that that's going to
come up so if you guys could just take a
minute and let me know does anybody do
any training now and on cultural
competence is that is that a part of
your formal training program so if so
yes if not no and if you're not sure let
me know you're not sure and if you just
pick your answer then click vote that
would be great
I'm just going to wait for a minute oh
I'm going to keep on going oh ok so I'm
getting the results in now so sixty-six
percent do not um so that's a potential
of forty thirty four percent having it
or thirty four percent not sure and
having it so sixty-six percent no that's
what I thought I think we're still in
2010 there were two articles that were
published on this topic and one was by
Stacy print and Jai Mata where they
talked about um you know really really
needing to address redress address this
in the context of now we're really
working you know globally and we're
needing to develop virtual teams and
when we're needing to develop policies
across the world so really having a
better idea of of this it's going to be
able to make those kinds of things more
effective and then another article
earlier in 2010 by lien all worth and
all and others talked about diversity
and laboratory animal science issues and
initiatives and this article you know
recognize that we've been talking about
diversity in a workplace since the 80s
but really haven't been talking about it
a lot in laboratory animal science
community so really starting the
conversation about you know inclusion
promoting activities and doing a better
job there so excuse me so we'll go on on
and to each of these strategies
alright so on research I am going to
push out another pool but not just yet
let me talk about this for a minute my
next poll has to do with research I'm
curious to find out if anybody out there
is is Reese is using sort of structured
research to evaluate your training
programs in general here I'm talking
about coming up with some research
projects to help understand your
learner's perspective and actually if
you're interested in the cultural
competence and really want to focus on
that helping to to look at that
community and seeing what it's their
perspective remember are you know people
who are coming here to work are you
leaving their families are leaving their
country this this stuck out to be in an
article written by a veterinarian by the
name of la tessa hughes at the NIH where
she right to know these people are
really brave to come over here and so I
think a lot of times we get frustrated
when we're trying to get a job done and
trying to you know get our point across
when we really need to understand that
this is a really new thing so we need to
understand a learner's perspective so do
people you know so it's a good idea to
research these things so let's pause for
a second and in general do you does
anybody out there actually do you know
evaluate their programs in a formal way
by setting up you know like an our IRB
approved research project and this is
for just training programs in general
so why the results for that are coming
in um you know I I do know at least one
person who in one group who has done
research specifically she's she's she's
a she's a veterinarian at Penn State
Hershey College of Medicine an
incredible person and you can actually
pull up her one of our articles on on a
research project that she did in jail
ass I think it was just published last
year and I believe I had that in my
references on my slides um anyway you
know she was interested in you know they
went yeah they're interested in making
sure that there they have a really good
environment for their learners so they
implemented it a bunch of strategies to
help support their English language
learners but then she thought you know
we really should evaluate this to figure
out is it working is it not so they
actually did set up a qualitative IRB
approved qualitative research study to
do this now you do need um you know it's
not something you could just walk off
the street and do you do need
institutional resources and you do need
a little bit of training and you can
take a course on it but those of you
that are really interested in starting
to do these kinds of things you know
please do publish your research I asked
about training programs in general it
looks like sixty percent of you know ten
percent of you yes and twenty-eight
percent not sure so those of you who are
yes that's excellent own and please do
know make sure your publishing your
results because it's great for the rest
of us in the training community to be
able to see those results and be able to
use them to help make decisions at our
own places and maybe build on what
you're finding on so you can do research
through you know different ways you know
some call a qualitative research or
quantitative research formal or informal
you know getting results from interviews
surveys focus groups can really help you
improve your training just talking to
your lower
I really being interested in helping
them understand that you really do want
to make this the best for them for the
next next group it can be really helpful
so you know I do suggest that even if
right now you're doing it sort of
informally through surveys really try to
gather that information and analyze it
and see if you can you know use that to
help you make decisions on strategies
that you you are doing or strategies
that you feel will be helpful for the
group that you're focused on okay so
training lots of lots of strategies in
relation to training here so the one I
focus on in the first bullet is training
trainers and staff in cultural
competence so some of the articles i
share will provide some guidance on that
i do want to share a strategy that
andrea night from our and i'll share her
contact information she said it was okay
all these people that i'm mentioning
said it was okay for me to share their
contact information because they really
are primary resources for this kind of a
thing she shared a great program that
they did at their institution I'm really
immersing their staff in a situation
where they were in a training in a
different language and it really [ __ ]
was really great because there's eight
it was it was able to help them
understand what they needed to better
understand the material and some of
those strategies are actually shared
here so being able to and there are you
know there are people out there that can
help you you know either talk you
through what they did at their
institution or even people you can hire
to come on into your institution and do
some of these trainings for your staff
where you know and I think that's one of
my favorite ones where you put your
staff through an actual training session
on something new
in a different language another another
interesting method on doing training for
trainers or your staff is to help you
know help them try to learn a different
language you know in in a situation
where it's you know a workplace kind of
a situation and that's another way to
really get people feeling okay so this
is what they're going through this is
how they're feeling and it helps you
approach that person and understand your
audience and really makes a difference
on how you how you approach your
training and then there are ESL classes
English for speakers of other languages
these these kind of classes can be you
know some people get certified or
actually degrees in this thing but lots
of times there's um there are classes at
their local community college things
like that so those are always good to
share with your English language
learners to help them but also um have
one of your own so if you have a group
of people that are interested you can do
a lunch you know some some of the people
that I mentioned and and some other
colleagues that I work with will set up
on either lunchtime sessions or after
work sessions or on something like that
where you you could get together and
actually go through things maybe it's um
you know common vocabulary that's
happening in the animal facility or
there's a common non-compliance because
of not not understanding so you sort of
you know arrange your lessons around
that so for any of you that want to
learn more about that kind of a thing
those kind of programs feel free to
contact me after the session and I can
share that but that's really helpful too
because it not only gives gives
information you know vocabulary and
helping with that communication but also
really shows that true genuine focus on
trying to help
and then another thing is in your
trainings you know really talking with
you know your trainers and and your
stuff when they're when you're providing
things for English language learners
it's really helpful to point out you
know like using keywords and written
outlines a lot of times that visual you
know instead of like a whole manual or
just telling them something a lot of
times using a handing them a written
outline or or some key words is helpful
to because a lot of times they're
learning from people who if they learned
English in their home country lots of
times they learned it from somebody who
had the accent of the people in their
own country so their English might not
sound like the English that they're
hearing here and also different parts of
our country the english sounds different
so sometimes when you could write it
down the reading is a little bit easier
than the understanding audibly okay so
and this is another one of easy visual
in AZ strategy that can be implemented
in any of your main kinds of
interactions or trainings that you do
now the translated or bilingual signs
that sometimes isn't so straightforward
you know some institutions not a big
deal translate signs in all different
languages others institutions it's it's
not allowed you know that really depends
on institutional policy that kind of is
saying but think about how many signs we
have in the animal animal facility and I
mean definitely you need your
institutional approval if it is
something that's improved approved those
really important things that we need to
make sure especially those that are
higher risk for animal welfare kinds of
issues you know dude look at those
things and find out is it an area where
you could have
a picture or a translated sign or
something like that so this is this is a
picture those of you who do hands-on
training labs I'm sure you know even for
English you know people who are English
language learners the the pictures are
very very helpful they're helpful for
all types of learners as well as
different culture when you're having
different cultures and things like that
in the in the learning environment so
pictures translated or bilingual signs
so what kinds of visual aids have i'm
going to i just want to pause and get
some feedback from the audience could
you share some visual aids that you
might be using already in your facility
that that support your english language
learners and i'm going to watch the Q&A
box coming in and all share with the
audience what kind of signs or pictures
that you all are using to support your
english language learners now in your
facilities so we also have some pictures
simple signs short videos live demos and
then actually pointing out the words in
the protocol great thank you
okay all right and then I get two
strategies and I'm just going to share
some of my favorite tips there's lots of
great tips I might even add a couple
other ones i have in our resources
section an article I really highly
suggest that you read that includes
great tips on a great practical tips for
teaching English language learners so
silence is okay in all our culture we
like to fill in the silence you know ask
a question or something like that or ask
if there are any questions and if a
second going spy and nobody answers you
move on to the next thing when you have
a group of English language learners
silence is actually good you know so
just think about it if you were in a
situation where you didn't you were just
learning the language somebody asked a
question you've got to translate the
question right answer it in your head
and then translate it back so you can
answer it so it does take a little bit
of time so do make sure that that that
time is given also um you know different
cultures educated in different ways they
have different ways of you know dealing
with people that see they see as
teachers or it worth ority or things
like that so try to understand that
little bit too and be very very clear
about what's expected of them so you
must ask questions or questions are
encouraged asking questions is part of
this this training you know things like
that being very clear about you know
this is what I expect I expect you to
ask me I expect you to you know do this
that in the other so check to check for
understanding as we've all probably
experienced situations where we're
teaching and then people are like yes
yeah okay do you understand yes okay
make sure and we know this
as for those of you are trainers you
know show me tell me you know i mean in
a non-threatening kind of way and you
can do this by not put it you don't
really need to put people on the spot
when you're doing something like a
hands-on lab I think that's the best
easiest way to check for understanding
because you it could actually present
the information and then you can have
people demonstrate you know what what
you're talking about so that's I think a
really great way to to be able to check
for understanding some other places
might might not be as easy so if you're
doing a but if you're doing say a
facility orientation you might be
explaining a certain procedure for
something and then you could ask them
okay you know remind me how do we do
this again or show me where did I say
you know we get the euthanasia request
cards or something like that you know do
it in and non-threatening ways but
really check for that understanding
because you'll find out a lot of times
you don't have the understanding when
you think that you did I love this one
learn another language you can do it a
million different ways you know I mean
but you can go to the library you can
buy tapes you could you know you know go
to maybe a section in town that has a
you know that that is largely speaking
non-english and try to learn it that way
you know just somehow online there's
lots of resources so really try to learn
another language put yourself in their
shoes and that really does go a long way
and and not only that but learn their
language learning another language helps
you understand what they might be going
through a little bit but then if you
could just learn a few things that
really helps to and this is one of the
tips that on some of my my colleagues on
the panel shared really learn how to say
hello or goodbye or good day you know
things like that some really nice few
simple things and that will really help
with that connection which will help
them know that you're really trying to
help them and help them be more
engaged and more comfortable to let you
know if they're having a problem make
sure you keep your readers in mind when
writing I you know don't when you're
writing we talked about keywords and
outlines that's really helpful so try to
write as simple as you can and there
actually are many of you may know this
already but onward there there actually
are it there's a tool to check your word
counts and how simple and how what the
readability is of your of your writing
so if you're writing creating materials
that you're handing out you should be
checking your readability and the
article that I'm going to share really
goes into detail about you know some
tips for that and what that should look
look like and then if you really if this
is one of your favorite topics like mine
I'm not tesol certified that I hope to
get there someday you know go check
check into the local community college
if you're at the at a university check
into some of the classes that they had
their even um you know and see if you
could get you know this is this is part
of your life and this is something that
you are working with every day you know
get certified become more expert in this
kind of a thing and that will help you
be a better trainer and help things be
more effective when you're doing
training which will help you your
department your organization and and in
the whole research community great okay
okay so these are some of the resources
i wanted to share so the article that i
was talking about in the beginning by
dr. Stacy print some others is called
cultural competency and that's where it
talks about skills that are needed for
today's workplace to be competent in
this kind of a thing so that's a really
good one my other favorite one that I
mentioned a couple times was the tips
for training non-native English speakers
by let has a huge that was a huge sorry
in lab animal february2014 so i highly
suggest you check those out there
they're really helpful and then check
out your you know in university settings
cultural Resource Center's your
education departments your HR department
you know a lot of times we get so
focused in the work that we're doing and
work is very busy so a lot of times we
don't get time to you know focus on our
own professional development so it's
awesome that you guys are all here today
but really look for you know there is a
lot of stuff out there within your own
institutions that can help you support
either educating yourself better on
cultural competence on ideas on how you
can better support the English language
learning community and and a lot of
times especially in the university
environments they have you can work with
some other departments to help you set
up those research projects that i was
talking about so you can really evaluate
the effectiveness of some of the
strategies that you'd like to implement
or evaluate areas where strategy should
be implemented community college courses
are are good there's a lot of like I was
mentioning there's a lot of times you
Community College will have the tesol
teaching students of other other
languages certificates things like that
don't forget about the a last learning
library course I told you about of
course it was great in person
that's a really good one it really
provides a lot of just sort of basic
things good tips there and then
colleague so I have a few people to
recommend which I can share and um you
know talk to each other you know find
out what's find out what's working you
know find out what doesn't work and and
see how the better we do this that the
better we will be as a research
community which ultimately leads to
better science and and cures and
treatments for everybody so I believe I
have a PDF of this um that will be
provided I just wanted to point out that
i did put my reference it you know some
of my references on here and these were
mainly the articles that i pointed out
during my presentation and we're just
about ready for QA so i just found this
awesome picture the other day and it was
just so appropriate for our presentation
today when we help each other we really
help ourselves so when we help ourselves
we help each other it goes both ways so
i know you all are committed to creating
an a good environment for people were
that you work with both people and
animals so i wish you luck and let's go
open it up to some questions answers as
well as some feedback from you all on
some tips and strategies that you could
share with me and and the other people
on this on this webinar
thank you for that informative
presentation before you get started on
the question and answer session i would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of a
presentation window and again we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
first question is from Nancy a day
charles river laboratories she asks as
an English language learner is it
mandatory to speak American English good
point okay so when you say American
English I'm imagining you mean American
versus British English I don't think so
but i am not an expert on I think what I
don't think so if you're talking between
American English and British English I
don't think it matters although if you
talk British English some some people
might not understand so you might just
need to explain because some some words
are a little bit different but in
general I think you'll be fine but don't
know of any sort of mandate that would
would require that I hope that helps
Jennifer on reign of mcgill university
asks how do you differentiate between a
failed exam theory course and a language
barrier and there's another question too
but let's yeah let's answer this one
first and then we'll move to to the next
one well maybe you want to answer both
how can we go about this in a nicest way
possible that's that's a great question
and I didn't address assessments in in
this at all but on that's great so I
would suggest if if the exam was only
given one way i would i would personally
assume that it was a language barrier
and provide you know benefit of the
doubt and provide the evaluation another
way a lot of times you can give an
English language learner a written test
which they fail but you can give them
either an oral test or require some sort
of a demonstration of the the material
and they pass with no problem and that
helps you answer that question so so
recommend two ways always two ways of
evaluating so Angela croucher from the
University of Kentucky says or asks you
how do you differentiate I'm sorry sorry
but could you please repeat which klas
course you were mentioning earlier yes
um so I might back on
okay sorry about that anyway um yeah I'm
sorry it's cold I pleats called teaching
it's in the training session is section
and it's called teaching I think English
says a second language students have
english as a second language I can't
remember the title the to the tips of
course as much as I've gone to it so if
i can i can ask the organisers how i can
send that out to everybody you could
actually also submit questions during
the on-demand period so if you send me
that question i will send it the title
right over to you okay unfortunately we
are out of time I want to thank the
audience for their interesting questions
and participation in today's event and
you will be able to submit more
questions during the on-demand period
which I'll be telling you about in just
a moment on today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
august twenty fifths so again continue
to submit your questions you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay and we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye